und wir stehen vor einem langen
wochenende meine damen und herren viele
von ihnen waren wahrscheinlich heute
einkaufen haben ist einmal mehr erlebt
vieles vieles ist richtig teuer geworden
obst im schnitt 9 prozent teurer gemüse
elf prozent teurer fleisch und wurst 18
prozent teurer und die große frage die
sich stellt wenn für uns das einkaufen
schon teuer geworden ist was ist
eigentlich mit den köchen was ist
eigentlich mit den gastwirten christian
lohse der teuer shop für uns bürger ist
der gleichzeitig gleichzeitig auch der
gäste killer für die gastwirte für die
gastronomie
ja dieser vorschau auf das weiß ich
nicht so ganz genau wir haben ja immer
eine spezielle klientel bedient aber wir
hatten das große glück dass 50 bis ohne
alle im restaurant sitzen hatten denn
wir hatten auch ein mittagsangebot für
relativ kleines geld 18 euro eingang
aber werden auch mit 540 euro pro kopf
umsatz die ich eines der höchst präzisen
restaurants europas man muss also ein
restaurant sollte populär sein und nach
oben nicht limitiert seien auch im preis
also der stadt essen will ich involviert
einkaufen können was jetzt natürlich
passiert ist ich sage es mal so wir sind
daran gewöhnt den letzten jahren dass
die preise sehr weit unten waren wir
haben zehn prozent des nettoeinkommens
ausgegeben für essen und trinken dann
kam kurvig weißmann riesensprung jetzt
haben uns daran gewöhnt dass uns essen
geliefert wird das kostet auch geld
durch die transportwege boxen wurden
gemacht da hängen ganz viele dinge dran
aber das erste mal das ich erlebt habe
in meiner zeit also als ich koch
lehrling wurde vor 7 30 jahren hat man
in familien gesagt du hast immer zu
essen du hast immer zu trinken und ist
jemand zimmer das stellte der patron zur
verfügung jetzt zwar erst mal ohne
arbeit also in restaurants waren
geschlossen und wir konnten keine berlin
werden natürlich die möglichkeit dass
wir liefern wollen aber ich hab mich
dagegen entschieden denn es gibt ja
nicht nur 56 es gibt ja auch andere
mensch auf dieser welt und als ich die
ersten kartons versteckt hatte und ich
aber selber so ein karton aufgemacht da
sage ich nur müll drin
verpackungsmaterial und so weiter und so
fort also sie sagen wir geben zu wenig
fürs essen aus georg a front ist das so
naja ich bin etwas entrissen dem
mehreren also erst mal ein kompliment an
sie sind einer der ganz wenigen
verbliebenen ihre zunft die das leben
genießen und anderen menschen freude
bereiten danke sehr dann das essen ist
eine ur sinnliche erfahrung die uns
manchmal selbst selbst uns in den
traurigen gedanken auffrischen kann ich
freue mich jeden tag auf das was ich es
ist ein geschenk gottes was konnten sie
am und in sofia und kohle blutig und
dazu wunderschöne pilze und danach noch
was ja also krabbeln oder schwänze in
dourdan ergänzt durch ein wunderschönes
auto und wir wollen es ja auch noch nun
geht man herz ja auch sehen sie wir das
sehen wir uns was ich nicht verstehe ist
ihre yamaha
denn sie sind ein segment da ist die
richterskala nach oben offen ich muss
ihnen ganz ehrlich sagen in sotschi
nicht verkehren kostet die vorspeise 36
einmal forschung als 36 euro die
der sag mal der steinbutt von dem sie
gesprochen haben baby steinbutt zu viert
auf spinat mit einem haufen
78 euro dazu natürlich einen
wunderschönen wein ein
toller manier oder ein motorschiff nicht
aus der spitzenklasse sind nur noch gar
nicht in dem bus angekommen die dann zum
auto kurz erwähnt werden ihre kundschaft
da können sie verdoppeln und
verdreifachen
die ist gegeben geht jeden preis mit
warum sie will unter sich sein den ist
ihr eigenes image verlosen sie können
kochen halten was sie im horning seine
man gelassen ich weiß es nicht er lernt
das ist dieses kleine das neue kleider
ich bin besser als ich widerspreche der
sache gar nicht also den steinbutt auch
für unter 20 euro verkauft motiv
vorspeise für 90 euro das problem ist
nur wenn die restaurants geschlossen
sind da wäre natürlich etwas ganz sicher
und dafür ein foul war er war also hab
ich will keine räuber so nervig
überspitzen gast sternekoch tv star aber
die frage ist ja auch von unseren
zuschauern kann sich eigentlich eine
menüwahl christian lohse leisten das
sind jetzt nicht so viele und ich glaube
das problem was sie ansprechen ist ja
eines was nicht nur für die
spitzengastronomie gilt sondern das gilt
ja auch für die gastronomie in der
breite her firma wann waren sie das
letzte mal im restaurant essen
blaue letzte woche letzte woche und das
was was gab es bei ihnen also war das
auch spitzengastronomie oder war das
eine currywurst
also weltweit 75 prozent der genutzten
landwirtschaftlichen fläche für die
tiere beansprucht das heißt zwei drittel
von allem wo wir was an bauen da wird
entweder tierfutter oder weideflächen
für die tiere genutzt das funktioniert
nicht mit fast acht milliarden menschen
das heißt er nämlich seit zehn jahren
vegan also ein pflanzlicher und
veganen restaurant und da gab es ja
gemüse reis und eine leckere soße dazu
ist das die zukunft so wie sie jetzt
essen weil sie auch gerade von den acht
milliarden menschen sprachen die er
ernährt werden müssen müssen wir uns
darauf einstellen fleischlos künftig zu
essen gibt es das schnitzel bald nicht
mehr also im moment ist so dass wenn
durchschnitts konsum in deutschland pro
kopf von 60 bisschen mehr noch kilo an
fleisch haben das funktioniert nicht
wenn wir acht milliarden menschen zu
ernähren wollen das heißt wir haben
heute schon probleme auf unserer erde
wenn wir alle so leben würden wie wir
hier in diesem raum dann bräuchten wir
mindestens drei weitere planeten die
gibt es aber nicht es gibt kein backup
planeten in unserem universum muss
einfach irgendwohin gehen können das
heißt die ernährung ist ein ganz
zentraler baustein um unseren
ökologischen fußabdruck zu reduzieren
wir sitzen gerade auf ungefähr elf
tonnen an treibhausgasen pro jahr
ausstoßen wenn wir das pariser
klimaabkommen ernst nehmen und sagen das
ziel 15 grad gemittelte erderwärmung
wollen wir halbwegs erreichen oder
zumindest die chance darauf bewahren
dann müssten wir auf 2,5 tonnen
reduzieren essen sie noch fleisch frau
sternberg er war nicht ich erste gelegen
rechner fleisch ja sie essen auch
fleisch wie sie gesagt haben sie aber
sind sie sonst auch jemand der veganen
mal kocht oder sonst wer auf
vegetarische ernährung wert legt wie
machen sie das sehr gerne sogar also ich
bin da super offen und findet vor allem
aber an deswegen sehe ich das auch eine
spannende sache sozusagen dass wir das
hier schon so breit diskutieren
was ich super wichtig finde ist dass man
selbstbewusst oder sich der sache
bewusst was es für konsequenzen hat und
ich glaube gegen hier in
unterschiedliche richtungen zum einen
geht es irgendwie darum okay was kann
ich für eine verantwortung in der
gesellschaft übernehmen in der die
klimakrise eben kurz bevor steht und was
kann ich dazu beitragen und ich
persönlich bin der auffassung dass es in
ordnung dass ab und zu ein stück fleisch
zu essen ich bin aber auch der
auffassung dass man das sehr bewusst tun
sollte und sich eben bewusst machen
solche woher zum beispiel das fleisch
kommt aus welcher tierhaltung etc leise
gesprochen christian lohse hat ja auch
gesagt es ist so viel dass so viel
teurer geworden die korona panne war
beim thema eine frage hätten eher ruhig
keine in die server bei der frage sind
preise ist denn dann zum beispiel
fleisch noch zu billig aus ihrer sicht
also ich glaube
ja die discount fleischabteilung
bestimmt ich glaube dass wenn der preis
steigt und das ist sicherlich auch ein
guter anreiz um das so zu sehen dass man
sagt okay vielleicht gibts einfach auch
vielleicht macht gemüse genauso viel
spaß und ich kann es irgendwie auch ja
irgendwie so zubereiten dass es dass es
mir schmeckt ich glaube aber auch dass
zum beispiel wenn jetzt über
verbraucherpreise hin ich weiß jetzt
nicht ob
es jetzt wirklich die gastronomen
deswegen besonders hart trifft aber wenn
wir über verbraucher weise zu sprechen
dann geht es natürlich auch darum dass
wir uns die sozusagen die ursachen
anschauen und das ist natürlich zum
einen unsere sanktionen im ukraine krieg
und zum anderen
ja sozusagen das dass bestimmte währungs
oder
ist richtig es kommen die haben das
problem getreide beispielsweise wir
sehen beim thema milch eine sehr extreme
verknappung beziehungsweise stärkeren
nachfrage genau aber was mich an ihre
argumentation stört an der ganzen
bewegung in welcher
selbstverständlichkeit sie sagen es wird
in deutschland zu viel billiges fleisch
konsumiert sie gehören unter garantie zu
einer einkommensgruppe die in gehobenen
gastronomie und auch im gehobenen
verkaufsstätten geben butter lindner
solche leben ja und andere sie gehören
gehöre nicht zu denen die im monat netto
haben zwischen 2.000 und 3.500 das sind
leider 80 dem würde ich mal teil
widersprechen gerade weil sie die hartz
iv empfängerin nein das habe ich auch
nicht gesagt du weißt doch wie stellen
wir sozusagen gerade nutzen butter
lindner zu gehen aber ich bin zum
beispiel meine ich koche wahnsinnig
gerne selber ja aber und wer nicht ab
und dann bis zum gehtnichtmehr sie
sollen sich breit in der bevölkerung ist
oder wie sich das was sie hier vorbeben
ja das gar nicht einfach nicht leisten
können das ist eben diese erziehungs
elite der vermeintlichen die sie sich
stimmten zu sein also das problem ist
doch lassen wir uns gar nicht leisten
können dass wir nun alle so leben hier
die rollen oder problem räumen davon
jedem menschen morgen eine karte in den
briefkasten zu stecken was zu essen hat
am besten ist das nicht nur
ein sieg es geht um bewusstsein und aus
ihrer freien entscheidung heraus weil
wir uns dessen bewusst sind was unser
ernährung aus aber sie dürften sich
besser zu sein als andere weil sie ihren
penis keine schwere untertöne hatte für
mich kommt es vor allem darauf an dass
genau nicht der staat eben vorschreibt
was sollte ich erstmal was nicht aber
was ich gerne möchte es das durch aktive
aufklärungskampagnen informationen und
bildung an die bürgerinnen und bürger
gegeben werden was man vielleicht selber
als bürgerinnen und bürger auch in der
hand hat um zb der klimakrise
entgegenzuwirken losen officer sowie gab
sie vegetarisch bei ihnen muss man also
sagen irgendwie kannte er berühmt für
vegetarische gerichte auch sehr berühmt
ich habe eine serie von 35 verschiedene
soßen bis auf einen sind alle vegan aber
nicht aus dem prinzip heraus wenn sie
obst gemüse verarbeiten dann erschließt
sich das eigentlich ganz alleine dass
sie halt faktisch vegan oder vegetarisch
sind ich finde das problem was ich noch
bewegen haben das war schon immer so die
vegane fraktion oder versucht also
politisch darzustellen hat es versäumt
erstes mal gute lieder zu haben und
zweitens eine eigene sprachführung zu
haben und drittens haben sie es nie
geschafft eine ausgewogene ernährung
tatsächlich darzustellen sie müssen also
da aber was wir manchmal ein größeres
problem doch das hat davon gerade
angesprochen man hat den eindruck wenn
man nicht vegan lebt dass man eigentlich
ein mensch mittlerweile
ist es gibt nur moralischen zeigefinger
vegas er charmant wie sie das
einmal das sozusagen stringent nach
vorne bringen dafür rede sie reden aber
das sieht das sehr schnell doch ringen
ist der eindruck das ist diesen
moralischen zeigefinger gibt also
erstmal gibt es diesen moralischen
zeigefinger hab ich ja fast ganz anderes
kommt werden wir waren in den letzten
halben jahr auf zwei großen messen der
größten messen der welt und wir haben
künstliche nahrung gesehen die mir
vorbei mal zu holzspänen der geest eine
brühe drüber ich habe die inhaltsstoffe
gesehen also eine liste von ungefähr 100
zutaten stoffen das wie tomaten die auf
mineralstoffen wachsen dank einer tomate
aus dem garten und dann nimmt er nach
fünf minuten decke runter und nennt das
dann veganes pulled pork
das ist dass das wird die neue zukunft
seit wir glaube ich essen werden es
werden nicht die gemüse sein ist hier
durch das fleisch oder fisch sein damit
werden wir versuchen die welt zu
ernähren was da rauskommt kann ihnen
jetzt schon sagen durch die fähre
mangelernährung gerade von kinder die
wir haben internet zu schlagen die hände
über dem kopf zusammen indem sie sagen
sechs jahre kommen zu uns weil sie nur
von sich von burger ketten sowas ernährt
haben und die haben marga darm
verschlüsse und ähnliche krankheiten und
die sind kaum zu retten also wir müssen
uns damit beschäftigen dass wir weniger
konsumieren es muss nicht immer alles zu
jeder tages und nachtzeit verfügbar sein
und wir müssen uns auch darauf
konzentrieren das ist etwas mehr auf
unserem grund einkommen ausgeben und das
heißt nicht dass der stein oder trüffel
essen